in Europe are you ready yes sir have fun
I'm not gonna go easy
well Nathan Gunner congratulations guys
you're moving forward in the third and
final rounds competition you made your
first blades out of guillotines and
we're going to continue on with the
darker side of History Theme by asking
you to build this blade four days
the Executioner sword
[Music]
the Executioner sword performed its
bloody work in 16th century Central
Europe unlike combat swords this lethal
blade features a straight double-edged
cutting blade with a blunt tip perfect
for swiftly chopping off the heads of
criminals this deadly weapon was used on
many aristocratic felons rather than the
ax since it allowed the victim to meet
his end in a dignified kneeling position
rather than face down with his head on
the Block while The Executioner's sword
fell out of use in the early 18th
century this gruesome sword is still
wielded in the 2019 video game Mortal
the boys miss good luck we will see you
in four days
my name is Nathan Anderson from West
Valley Utah I'm a maintenance worker at
the Utah's Hogle Zoo I loved animals and
there's not too many places where I can
be Weld and look up and see a giraffe
right there if I went Fortune fire the
ten thousand dollars is gonna go to
taking my wife on a trip to go looking
for bigfoot heat treat coming up just
don't want to rush it I don't want to
break it because that would be bad
all right
I don't think that anything went wrong I
feel pretty good about the quench should
be able to clean everything up and move
on forward from here so now it's time to
start working on the guard I've got my
finials right there hopefully those
won't add too much weight for what I
want to go for but I think I'm sitting
pretty good for right now there we go
I've got the guard fitting where I want
it to I need the handle comfortable so
that it's not a reason to be sent home
because it's going to get and then we'll
pin it
so I start engraving skulls and some
flames and things like that to kind of
make it my own pretty close
give it a test
this blade is so good I can smell
Bigfoot now
my name is Gunner Wilbanks I'm a high
school football coach and teacher and
I'm part-time bladesmith my wife loves
it every time I make a knife I bring it
in to her both of my daughters and my
son they all have to hold it as it turns
out we all love Blaze
a few hours in and I'm almost halfway
there kind of forgot what it was like in
a little man's world just working with a
hammer because I don't have the power
tools I'm having trouble getting it
heated evenly because my storage is
short every time I slide my blade
through it's so long it wants to droop
on one end well every time that I'm
getting down here and getting the back
end of it hot the front end of it is
cooling off we gotta get the timing
right right here I get it in the quench
tank
I don't feel any Tings I don't feel any
cracks anything like that
that's not a sign you want to hear it's
soft on both ends that's not going to
work plan B is to go in for a second
Quench and instead of laying the blade
flat I'll lay it upright maybe I'll be
able to hold the heat a little bit
better that way and the blade's not
going to Sag on me if the quench doesn't
go well I go all the way back and start
at Ground Zero
thank you Jesus
thank you I'm elated that I'm actually
going to be able to use this blade it
seems to be going great
all right so far so good and hopefully
God willing and the creek don't rise
they might say you're the forge and fire
champion
it will kill you
basements welcome to the Keel test
the Executioner sword that word alone
just gives you visions of decapitated
heads so to find out what kind of lethal
damage your executioner sword can do
I'll deliver some while lethal blows on
this ballistics dummy
Nathan is it time it's time have fun
crap
just a little off the top
all right Nathan first stop this is a
heavy Beast it is so forward heavy that
you eat two hats to control that now
your handle construction is smooth I'll
give you that but it also feels a little
bit rounded over here where it actually
gives me much more control sideways than
it does this way but overall your
weapons sir filled with Keel awesome
all right Gunner your turrets are you
ready absolutely let's do this
[Music]
all right Gunners talk about your
executioner sword over here your blade
right here has a finer grind so it makes
it a little bit lighter and the edge
that you have here when it came to that
skull just glided into that overall sir
your execution your sword it'll kill
like it
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the skull and bone chop
now to test the overall construction of
your blades as well as how they feel
while they're being used I'll be
chopping into these skulls and that
nasty giraffe bone
Nathan you're up are you ready yes sir
have fun
[Music]
holy draft
all right Nathan so right off man this
thing is heavy but once you get it
moving it's going but controlling it's
tough having said that your Edge hella
beautifully it's still just as sharp as
when I started which is pretty darn
sharp so good job on that thanks I like
sharp things
what if I said no I'd say you don't
watch this so much do you exactly
[Music]
thank you
all right so gonna write off lighter
blade easier to control a lot of that
has to do with the fact you've got more
handle here
now your blade it's got some compacting
on the edges but I wouldn't run my
finger down this Edge it's still for
Lonnie sharp nicely done thank you sir
all right blade Smiths this is the
sharpness test the Jackfruit and water
jug slice
Ethan you're up first you ready yes sir
have fun all right let's do this
[Music]
still Sharp
all right Nathan as far as the downward
chop it's a very clean cut easy no
resistance whatsoever now when I was
cutting as soon as I met the resistance
of the water it kind of rolled on my
hand
but anything that it did have contact
with it was able to cut overall sir your
weapon it will cut thank you
all right go under your turn so you
ready yes sir I am let's do this
foreign
[Music]
ER the handle construction you have here
is wide and oh void enough to where when
I hold on to it I can really tell where
the edge is and it's much easier to
control a blade like this in the slice
you can see that cuts nicely overall sir
your weapon it will cut thank you
the boys Miss only one of you can leave
here with the title of Fortune fire
champion and get that check for ten
thousand dollars now the judges
discussed your blades and they made a
final decision
today's Fortune fire Champion is
Gunner congratulations now Nathan you
fought hard man but unfortunately your
blade didn't make the cut I'm gonna have
to ask you to please step off the fourth
floor thank you very much
congratulations
well I'm gonna have to find a different
way to take my wife to go see Bigfoot
but we're still gonna go
well Gunner that makes you the forge of
fire Champion you just got yourself a
check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations thank you appreciate it
guys
I just won forged in fire feeling good
well I mean I've never thought I would
make it this far from day one I don't
necessarily think that I'm a better
Smith than any of these other guys that
just worked out in my favor today as far
as the money uh after football season
ends my wife and I will probably take a
long weekend somewhere
well Ryan Matt gentlemen congratulations
the two of you have made it past the
first forging round in our best and
domestic competition which means that
the two of you are going back to battle
it out from your home forges for four
days now Ryan because you impressed the
judges most in the first round with your
blade you get the choice of one of these
three blades to build against your
competitor here now we've got the Hook
sword
the killage
and finally the panabus
what are you thinking let's go with the
killage the killage all right
the killage traces its Origins back to
the 15th century Ottoman Empire
this lightweight sharp curved blade was
specifically designed to be wielded
signal-handedly making it ideal for
warriors on Horseback to deliver deadly
slashes upon enemy attackers this
formidable weapon was previously
featured on season five of forged and
fire where both Smiths overcame
complications with the length of the
blade and the ornate longer but
ultimately an extreme Bend taken during
the strength test cost one Smith the
competition
good luck we will see you in four days
good luck hey good luck man
I'm Ryan Searles I'm a 20 year old
artist in bladesmith from Thornton
Colorado I've always loved to craft and
build things with my hands and when I
found out I could play with fire and
Hammer steel I mean come on what's not
cooler than that I want to shoot for a
braided Mosaic Damascus
[Music]
I'm going to stack up fill it of about
28 layers Forge it out chop it into
tiles and I'm able to create a braided
Mosaic I got this sword forged out to
where I want it to be and I'm ready to
go for the heat treat alrighty if I
don't get this played hard I could be
out on this oh yeah we gotta work
there's a slight warp to the right so I
know I got to put it between two two by
fours and clamp it up otherwise if I
can't get that warp out now it's gonna
bite me in the butt later
that's pretty straight
I want to fit the long Jays and handle
together I has to be inlaid just so I
can get a very tight and nice fit up so
it's time to get the blade into the acid
and see this pattern pop all right
moment of truth
look at that oh yeah we got a killage I
brought my a game can't wait to see what
Matt does and can't wait to hopefully
get that 10K there we
my name is Matt Roberts I'm 41 years old
and I've been making knives for about 20
years now I've been practicing law now
for about 14 years my goal is to win the
competition so I can have the bragging
rights and frankly being sufferable to
my friends
more so than I am already I'm forging a
coarse ladder pattern in this Blade the
hardest part of this build is going to
be forging the Damascus and making sure
I have a very solid Billet this far into
the process if the blade fails
making another blade in the time
remaining is frankly impossible
yeah
we're good
I want to have more mass in the handle I
also want to be able to have a bigger
more contoured handle than be more
comfortable to the user I have the
handle rough-shaped
there's some gapping between the handle
and the guard try to fill these the best
I can I don't think any of the flaws are
going to affect its functionality
they're just cosmetic and they're ugly
got the handle done
that doesn't look half bad I think
overall it came out okay I'll be looking
forward to seeing the sword used I think
that would be fun
foreign
test
Ryan you're up first you ready for this
let's let's do it
all right Ryan let's talk about the
Achilles sword here first up I
appreciate the beauty of the Damascus
pattern you have there also what I like
about this is that it's got that classic
killitch look where you got parallel
lines and then slowly curve up that's
what we like with a historical piece
like this now you're handled
construction everything is smooth no
sharp corners on that your Edge is sharp
it almost cuts through all the way on
the big carcass and the the Tommy mats
overall your weapon it will kill awesome
Matt your turn you ready I'm ready
foreign
[Music]
it's not quite the historic accurate
killage because you don't have those
parallel lines it immediately goes down
into a curve your handle construction is
also not the typical killage look but
your Edge is razor sharp you've got a
very nice balance to wield this weapon
and overall your killage will kill thank
you very much
placements Welcome to our Dynamic
strength and cutting test
I'm going to attempt to cut through
these Vines and smash these skulls I'm
not going to go easy I'm gonna have fun
with these and Ryan you're up first you
ready to go let's break some skulls
wow
nice job Ryan your Edge is still very
very sharp so no glinting or anything
cut beautifully
and overall tested very well good job
awesome thank you
all right Matt it's always more fun for
the second guy right I'm ready oh I'm
ready too let's go
thank you
all right Matt nice job thank you I like
the blade I like the weight the Damascus
came out beautifully you have the
slightest bits of glinting I mean it's
very minimal your handle
little unorthodox and right in this area
I wish I'd round it off a little bit
more right because it's a little bit
sharp right where my thumb sits on this
part but nothing's loose nice job thank
you very much
well gentlemen you gave us two swords
that performed outstanding in our tests
but at the end of the day only one of
you can leave here as a fortune by a
champion getting a check for ten
thousand dollars after discussion our
judges did make a final decision
today's sports fire Champion is
Ryan congratulations Matt you missed out
by just a little bit and Jay's going to
tell you why Matt you brought us a great
sword and a great performer you should
be very proud of what you did but you
did have a little bit of glinting on the
skulls during the strength test and the
handle it's got some hot spots and I
could feel him when I'm swinging it big
thing though is the historical accuracy
what you brought us is a little bit off
from the traditional killage and that's
why we're sending you home I understand
well Matt you brought us a beautiful
blade that did perform extremely well
but unfortunately your time in this
competition has ended I'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor congratulations man great job
thanks man the whole thing it was fun it
was exciting it was challenging it was
everything I was looking for
well Ryan congratulations that makes you
a fortune fire Champion you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars man congratulations thank you
[Applause]
forged in fire Champion what oh man it
feels good I mean that was a insane
competitor this feels good to make it
through all the tests and uh the 10
grand hey that's just a plus to me
Jordan Jesse congratulations it is now
between the two of you to figure out
who's going home with the title of Forge
of fire champion and a check for ten
thousand dollars now in the final round
of competition you guys are going back
home to work on an iconic weapon from
history and that weapon is
the headhunter's ax
the Headhunter ax is both a tool and a
weapon of the native igora tribe who
hail from the mountains of the
Philippines featuring a sharp Spike on
one side that is used to pierce Shields
and armor it also contained a wide
lethal ax head on the other side
designed to swiftly decapitate enemies
in the heat of battle an intimidating
weapon tribes would display the heads of
their victims to strike fear into their
enemies the legacy of this deadly ax
lives on today and can be seen in the
video game State of Decay breakdown
good luck we will see you in three days
we're back day one at my home Forge here
in Santa Ynez California I'm going to be
making a headhunter's
Axel's temperature but this is
definitely a pivotal moment to know that
my porch bugs are set and they're really
nice and at the homogeneous piece of
Steel all the way through so this has
got to be perfect right now
[Music]
I'm really excited to see that it's
actually 4 12. today the biggest hurdle
is going to be that heat treat it's a
weird shape let's hope everything goes
well that thing just doesn't fit in
there very well this is a little
nerve-wracking making sure that it is
perfectly heated across the board
there we go
[Music]
we got a definite warp right there I
need to run into my straightening jig
straighten it and let it sit and wait
oh man it's perfectly straight yes
only one day left we're gonna try and
get some pins through here to make sure
that not only we have a chemical
connection to the blade but we have a
mechanical connection we're through
now I'm gonna get everything pretty much
to final finish
yeah she's Sharp
I'm back in my home Forge here in
Medford Oregon I don't really have any
time to make mistakes kind of my
strategy is to draw out the spike in
first that's going to be the hardest and
longest thing to draw out so I get done
forging and now it's time for the Quench
and uh I'm feeling pretty nervous I feel
like my guts are in my throat
thank you
oh yeah
we didn't have this hard we're sitting
pretty good for day two
I'm getting all the final touches on the
ax head I really want to make sure that
I get this ax nice and sharp I opened up
a seam where my weld had met the actual
socket if I weld on this for too long
then it's going to ruin my heat treat
I think we got it the bladesmithing gods
have looked out for me the Gap is gone
so relieved right now I was doing a
little bit of research on the Warriors
of this tribe and I noticed that there's
certain tattoos that they give Warriors
after they've behead somebody so I'm
going to incorporate some of those
designs into the handle that way it'll
give some good traction but also look
badass
thick coat on there it's looking really
nice but I really want to see if my edge
geometry is there so I decided to do a
cut test
oh I feel so much better on round two of
my knife it did not cut very well so to
know that I'm actually able to make
something that can cut and do it well it
feels really good I'd say it's a pass in
my book
gentlemen welcome back to the forge both
your blades look absolutely deadly but
there's really only one way we can find
out if they are as deadly as they look
we've got a strength test a sharpness
test and up first The Kill
[Music]
ladies Miss welcome to the Keel test
the igarot Headhunters ax a weapon that
I've always fantasized about because
it's very close to my Filipino Heritage
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your headhunter's ex will do I will take
your weapon and deliver some lethal
blows on this ballistics dummy Jordan
are you ready because I am so let's do
this
right now I'm pretty intimidated if that
Spike hits the backbone or the skull or
anything like that I think could snap
right off
all right
all right Jordan let's talk about your
Headhunters ax here your edges here are
very sharp with every strike it dug in
very deep into this ballistics dummy the
spike you have here even digging into
the skull did not bend it feels good in
the hand and more importantly sir
people kill thank you
all right Jesse you're up next are you
ready I'm ready let's do this
I'm feeling nervous I'm worried about my
ax head flying off the socket because
those bones are dense you know going
into a human skull is not an easy task
s
oh he head-butted me
all right Jesse let's talk about your
headhunter's ax over here first up the
handle construction somebody did some
research in some Polynesian tattoos
there looks good and it feels good in
the hand your edges here penetrated very
deep into this ballistics dummy now your
Spike here not only did it penetrate the
skull but it also cut it and it stayed
true overall sir your headhunter's ex
little Keel thanks Doug
all right gentlemen Welcome to our
strength test the bamboo and skull chop
now you get two totally different
materials here you got the springy
bamboo that likes to bounce things back
and the skulls at like the break edges
so we're going to test both ends and the
overall construction of your Headhunters
axes turn your smile as you're up first
how about that yes sir okay let's do it
ah
[Music]
Jordan nice job take a breath now
everything held up nicely
everything's tight doesn't look like
anything moved your edges are still
sharp I mean the fact that you made this
thing light tough and into Damascus in
three days that's a heck of a feat good
job thank you
all right Jesse how you feel after
seeing that not good not good it'll be
fine
[Music]
foreign
man
all right Jesse on the plus side
it felt great in the hand
and your edges held up just fine
but just all the shock wave from The
Forest of those strikes split the handle
almost in half so definitely not going
to be able to continue testing with this
weapon
well Jesse we absolutely hate to see
that happen phenomenal job on your blade
itself but unfortunately you had a
catastrophic failure when your handle
broke and for that reason we can no
longer continue testing your weapon I'm
gonna have to ask you to please leave
the forge
I felt a little heartbroken seeing
something that I put so much work into
would be broke but I came onto this
competition just to prove that I can
compete with some of the best blade
Smiths out there and I know I've already
accomplished that so I still feel like
I'm going home a winner
well Jordan you survived the test your
blade came out on top so congratulations
you are the forge and fire champion and
there's a ten thousand dollar check
waiting for you outside that door very
well done
I just won fours on fire I don't really
know what to say right now Sasquatch is
kind of my mascot and so I feel like
that's a Sasquatch worthy Acts
foreign
congratulations you've both made it into
the final round of this competition now
we're sending you back to your home
forges to recreate an iconic weapon from
history
that weapon is
h
sweet
vicious and menacing the berdish was a
favorite of Eastern European infantry
soldiers during the 16th and 17th
centuries its large crescent-shaped ax
head measured nearly two feet at the
edge and could cleave through flesh and
Bone specialized soldiers called strozsy
would use the barticious pole to balance
their muskets for firing from a distance
then switch to their acts during melee
combat though rare in American pop
culture you can experience the
barticious savagery on the virtual
Battlefield in the game Chivalry
medieval warfare good luck blade Smiths
we'll see you in five days all right
day one my name is Michael Peterson I've
been picking up a hammer before I could
even ride a bike learning and just going
out there after my dad would get done
forging and just Tinker around smashing
hammers 23 years later I'm still making
blades oh yeah now we got a good fire I
use a coat forward because it's what I
grew up on I'm using 5160. there we go
beautiful sound ain't it move on to the
handle I'm gonna start shaping down here
leave less here turn on the grinder got
a belt on there as soon as it gets going
yeah snaps hits me right in the chest
ouch
these holes in the bar dish blade blade
a little lighter
okay
I got all the holes drilled all the way
through yeah looks pretty cool I think
I'm feeling a little nervous about the
heat treat all right the moment of truth
Lord let this go well
my magic clutching hoping for a hard
edge and a soft spine therefore
reinforcing the blade
here we go
foul test
oh yeah we got her yeah
everything's ready to put together
I have a little concern about the weight
just to look
like that a little bit front and heavy
does bother me a little but at this
point not much I can do about it
my name is John wigger I'm 28 years old
one of the things I'm actually known for
is I shave stuff into my chest it's one
time I won a sweater contest by shaving
a Christmas tree in my chest so I
thought that when I win ten thousand
dollars shave enable into my chest
I'm gonna try to just focus on the blade
because this is the most important part
of my build
I have to get the blade heat treated I
don't got a quench take big enough so I
had to fabricate a quench tank so I'm
gonna see if we put liquid so I know if
I can fill with my oil got some leaks
out of my put some plastic in it and
maybe line with tin foil try to keep the
heat away from the plastic you may be
wondering what's going to happen when
the oil gets hot inside there and I may
be wondering the same thing now I'm
going to stick my blade in the Forge and
normalize it a few times and then I'm
going to go in for my heat treat I just
hope this thing holds up
I'm more worried about glistening for
cracks or anything than I am about
burning my shop down at the moment then
my oil starts leaking out
so I decided to take the blade out but I
think I got a hard blade so today I get
to start on all the little detail work
on the blade I'm going to try to
incorporate maybe like a dragon type
thing on one side and maybe a bunch of
uh just designed on the other
so then I'll put that in acid it'll eat
away everywhere beside the paint
and then after that I'll wipe off all
the paint and you should get a nice
shiny uh finish from where the paint was
and then kind of a rustic patina look on
the rest of the blade so it's just one
big piece of art as well as a weapon
all right leads bits this is the Keel
test
we'll find out how lethal your weapon is
I will take your bardish and deliver
lethal chops on this big carcass
John you're up first you ready let's do
it let's do this
[Music]
nice head on brother
all right John's talking about your
bardiche here I love the swells by
putting these welds right there it
allows me to adjust my hand and get a
good grip every time I move it around
your blade right here is razor sharp
cuts through spine bones and thick flesh
overall sir your bardish
will kill I got something to show you oh
sure kill tests
all right Michael your attorney got
anything to show me nope all right you
ready for this yes sir let's do this
nice
foreign
Michael this is at least around 11
pounds all forward wheat
I waste so much energy in recoiling that
could be used in attack
but overall sir your badish
will kill yeah
mate Smith welcome to the strength test
the stump thump and steer smash to test
the strength and durability of your
bardishas as well as their overall
construction I'll be chopping
mercilessly into these logs and cleaving
that steer skull in half remember this
is all about what happens to your
bardish and not what happens to the
wooden bone John you're up first you
ready let's do it
nice
awesome well John you're uh bardish it's
got a nice weight to it
not a huge fan of these undulations in
the handle because I want to be able to
move my hands around
I'm looking at the edge it held up
beautifully everything's still straight
and tight good job thank you
Michael you're up next ready oh yeah
hope you ate your Wheaties
oh boy
all right
well Michael first things first this
thing is heavy it's a beast but uh
everything is still tight there's no
Motion in it even after all of that
chopping and smashing of skulls The Edge
held up really well so well done that's
awesome yeah up next is the sharpness
test and for that I give you the date
all right gentlemen now unlike the
strength test this is all about with
your blades do to the Target so take a
one shot right down the middle trying to
split those watermelon put half in one
bucket half in the other all right
Johnny you ready let's do it okay
nice
all right John it feels good it's got a
good balance to it the shape of this is
really nice The Cutting Edge curved like
that cut through the watermelon
beautifully sharp Weapon It's nice
enough thanks all right Michael you're
up are you ready bring out the Beast
okay
foreign
well right off it's definitely sharp but
it weighs a ton I like the design of
this
build strong doesn't necessarily mean
build heavy
John Mike you blade Smiths have engaged
in one of our most difficult
competitions however only one of you can
be the forged fire champion
Champion is
[Music]
John congratulations you're our new
Forester fire Champion Mike
unfortunately your weapon didn't make
the cut please surrender your weapon
my experience here was definitely a
challenge coaching me to my limits I
learned a lot
I might not be the torch and fire
Champion but I still feel like I'm
walking away a winner John
congratulations you're the new forged
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for how much and
Graham please present your bardish to
the judges this is the most mentally
physically emotionally stressful time
also the best time in my life
origin fire Champion I'm super excited
to get home and tell my wife about the
great news and now the next thing coming
up I'm gonna be having a baby boy so I
mean this is a wonderfully here thank
God
foreign
congratulations you're moving forward in
the third and final round of this
competition you get four days of your
home forges to build another iconic
weapon from the wild west gentlemen we
want you to build this
this is the Vaquero machete
the Vaquero machete became widely
popular with the original Cowboys of the
Southwest during the 20th century
featuring a thin slightly curved blade
the weapon was much lighter and easier
to carry than the larger machetes
previously used by the Cowboys making it
ideal to deliver damaging slashes and
chops on everything from brush to
enemies on the great Frontier
the rich history and culture of the
Cowboys who carry this weapon can be
found on display at the Bullock Museum
in Austin Texas so good luck we will see
you in four days
my name is Gregory McClure I am 50 years
old I am from Tacoma Oklahoma knife
making has always been a deep-seated
passion my grandfather pulled me in when
I was 10 years old we found a piece of
metal alongside the road and ever since
then I started making custom knives all
right see this cooking like a June ride
okay
straight blade everything's coming out
nicely
it's like it's supposed to
the gas Foundry is what I'm going to be
making the guard and the pommel out of
carved the exact thing you want to cast
out of foam this is what it will look
like when we get done then you pack it
in green sand here we go you ready
and as you pour the molten metal on it
it evaporates the foam and leaves you
with the shape that you're desired that
was good guys
that's exciting and after a little bit
of sanding it looked great
[Music]
the one thing you need to worry about
with this kind of handle is not getting
your pieces glued well enough my
competition is going to be good but at
the end of the day he's going to bring
his best I brought my best we'll see
what happens
if that'll work
my name is Eric Finch I'm 20 years old
from Harmony Pennsylvania and I'm
bladesmithing for almost three years
when I first got into bladesmithing I
didn't have a lot of money and my uncle
Chuck he was super supportive he got me
my first Anvil he really had a lot of
faith in me getting into this and so
being here feels like it's uh finally
rewarding him for what he's done for me
my game plan is to start with Damascus
I'm going to start out with 20 pieces
shooting for a 60 to 70 layer in the end
so I got my build swelled it up in the
Forge last night got it quenched and in
the temper for today thinking about
started working on the palm oil when I
knew my dad my brother out hunting with
the Hawks I had him stop over so that
get a nice look at a 3D bird my dad's
been a falconer since before I was born
so I've always had Hawks my entire life
it's very lucky that I'm able to
incorporate this because that way I can
do a direct comparison I'm getting ready
to go into gluing the handle
and then once to get all the cleanup
finished pretty much all I have to do is
add an edge and it'll be done
and I'm really proud of how this looks
thank you
howdy Partners welcome to the Keel test
your Vaquero machetes look beautiful but
how lethal are they to find that out I'm
going to take care of machetes and
deliver some lethal blows on this big
carcass Greg you feel lucky oh very
lucky all right let's do this
foreign
Greg the leather wrapping that you have
here is nice and smooth the handle is oh
void the one thing though that's just a
lot of handle and because you have a
smooth handle right here a couple of
times my hand just slid down
but your edges are sharp those are razor
sharp Cuts well we're all sorry you will
kill thank you Doug
Eric your turn are you ready let's do it
let's do this
foreign
what I like about it is that it just
fits my hand perfectly so it's locked in
there now your Edge that's a Chevron
right there all the way up those are
very sharp deep Cuts even on thrusting
overall sir
it will Keel into here
Oliver carols Welcome to our strength
test the fence board and skull chop
hey Greg you're up first you ready yes
sir
foreign
right off blade hell up beautifully this
thing is just the sharpest one I started
feels like a great fighter to me only
complaint I have is that long handle but
other than that the Artistry is really
well done that's a joy to use nicely
done thank you
Eric you ready let's do it all right
all right so first off Eric very
different grind on this edge with that
secondary bevel but it's wicked sharp
and it's still sharp held up fine didn't
lose any blade at all no rolls no chips
nothing but still as straight as when I
started good job awesome thank you
late Smiths welcome to the sharpness
test the Gunslinger slice
[Music]
Greg you up first you ready for this
absolutely all right
foreign
Greg
nicely done those are very sharp clean
cuts on I'd say at least three layers of
clothing your weapon
it will cut
thank you
Eric your turn sir ready let's do it
let's do this
[Music]
foreign
Eric the edges are sharp enough to cut
through all layers and expose some of
the blood overall sir your weapon
you'll cut thank you
all right gentlemen well I gotta say
both of you impressed us from the very
beginning of this competition the first
two rounds you guys crushed it but this
competition as you know only one of you
can leave here as a fortune fire
champion and receive that check for ten
thousand dollars
the fortune fire Champion is
Eric congratulations you did it well
Greg I hope you had as much fun working
here as we had watching you that is an
unbelievably stunning piece but
unfortunately your time this competition
has ended I want to say thank you for
coming but at this point in time I have
to ask you to please step off the porch
floor thank you
I have no shame coming in second to this
young man the check would have been nice
the title would have been nicer but
remember I'm still the fastest blade in
the West
[Music]
well Eric you are the fortune fire
champion and you're receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you
crazy never thought I'd be here at this
young I don't even know how to react it
feels surreal from start to finish it's
been a crazy crazy competition and my
uncle keyless Prime my biggest drive to
Win It uncle Chuck this was for you